are with me for just one moment while I
start our LinkedIn live stream
take just a moment
and Welcome to our Lincoln livestream
audience our YouTube live stream
audience of course everyone here on
WebEx uh I'm Stuart Creek from Simply
learn and we are here today with Ronald
Van Loon
Ronald will be presenting uh the trends
for 2023 and Ai and Technology to enable
next to generation experiences which is
a fast developing area
of Technology
its applications
for people who are on
WebEx please
answer your questions in the Q a panel
you can put comments in the chat but the
questions for Ronald that you want him
to take in the question and answer
please put those in the Q a and we'll be
able to track them easier
uh if you're on one of the streaming
services put those in your comment or
chat box to be able to get them
translated here and
we have
uh
whole before and after his presentation
so we've got this one
bleed in and give us an idea of who's in
our audience today
that is
how many years of experience do you have
in the workplace
not necessarily an AI data science or
particular technology but
just how many years of work experience
do you have
and then
we do a check-in we've been doing that
throughout the pandemic on how people
are doing holding up with different
surges and things coming and going and
we're
in winter in the northern hemisphere so
we're getting more
coveted and flu and RSV coming so
we've been checking in on that and
here's the poll result
and
kind of a bimodal distribution we've got
a third of the audience who are still at
college or university a third who have
more than 10 years experience
and then evenly between
um and it's good to see that uh most
everybody is doing well or doing okay so
with that I'm going to
let Ronald speak about himself and we'll
get the presentation started
yeah thank you Stuart thank you I'm
rosaloon I'm the CEO at the intelligent
world and I share my knowledge on social
for already five years and I do that
with with great pleasure and to benefit
from it it I was announced as a top
influencer in several areas in data
science in big data and in Ai and today
yeah I want to to thank you for joining
us today we're going to have a
conversation about enabling the next
generation of experiences as Stewart was
mentioning it already where we're going
to discuss Ai and Technology trends for
for 2023
if I look ahead of 2023 it's it's almost
there just a couple of weeks this will
be a year that businesses will deepen
their digital transformation agendas
they worked on it a lot especially
during the covert period but they will
now further expand that they will
broaden their view of their business
operations and they maximize their
infrastructure output to support highly
connected social work and business
environments and their experiences now
organizations that have laid out a data
and AI driven technology Foundation
I think they are uniquely prepared to
deliver the next generation of type of
experiences and exceptional engagement
strategy in 2023 and this Foundation is
critical and most companies have been
forced to build this type of foundation
during the pandemic which really speeded
up the the digital transformation now
companies also must further integrate
and they must connect their data they
must get connected Technologies and
their capabilities to deliver this next
generation of experiences and what end
users are requiring is an immersive
virtual connected World which is driven
by the metaverse it's driven by super
apps it's driven by observability and by
sustainability and these are the four
topics that we're going to dive in today
in much more detail now at the same time
we see the business have to drive
visibility in all aspects of their
Enterprise so their data and their
technology like AI to they need to do
this to to deepen their understanding of
the impact of their transformation and
they need to consolidate and they need
to integrate their digital environments
into the physical environments now only
through enhancing visibility and through
driving automation across the Enterprise
can businesses collaborate and they can
do that at scale which is really
critical right now and drive accurate
decisions and do that in real time and
deliver Next Generation type of
experience which maybe I still have a
futuristic type of feeling but what you
will see the coming year is that AI will
substantially impact the experiences and
we dive deeper into this today now our
experiences are being shaped not only by
Technologies like AI but also 5G and
Cloud are very important foundation
because it's basically yeah the road the
foundation where you drive over if you
want to to deliver these type of
experiences
what you see is that organizations are
developing all kind of new Innovations
to meet his demands of fully connected
Virtual Worlds expanded by capabilities
like we call it XR extended reality or
by enhanced video type of streaming by
highly collaborative digital work
environments as everybody not everybody
but many people work remote and they
need to be able to collaborate in
digital environments of course and
consumers they have high demand for this
extended virtual experiences everywhere
where they go
and that's also let's say moving towards
business to B2B type of experiences
now if you look to Consumers whether
they want to live stream whether they
want consume video content whether they
want to shop to work or attend your
school or maybe you want to socialize
they all want to have this type of
experiences and a virtual and digital
realities what we see is that they are
converging a very nice maybe I was in
Bangkok where they presented
um let's say the metaverse but not with
an avatar but I was in the metaverse
um interacting with other people and
interacting in this case it was in a
um in some wood where there was pandas
and I could interact with the met in in
the metaverse and with other people not
as an avatar and that's let's say a Next
Level type of virtual uh virtual
experiences that you can expect in in
the coming years and we see that these
type of immersive experiences they are
really yeah driving the metaverse and
this is exploding in popularity
now businesses are scrambling to Define
what next Generation type of experiences
mean in the metaphors as well and how to
differentiate themselves in the future
through new Innovative type of metaverse
services and maybe it's hard to imagine
but to give a very simple ID the
metaverse in business to business you
can build a factory
digitally already run it and operate it
digitally that is the metaverse for B2B
and before you build a factory you run
it and you discover all the issues that
can occur before they occur before you
even start building
what we also see is that more
Millennials and gen Z's they are driving
the future of Workforce experiences and
they Define what is required for these
type of experiences now businesses are
trying to shape work experience as well
that are based on the functionality and
the convenience of mobile technologies
on your end keeping their core values of
Social and environmental sustainability
and in a world that's converging with
digital Technologies or the physical and
the digital type of Technologies
Workforce experiences of the future will
also be highly digital
I think it's good to remember that the
metaverse also encompasses virtual work
experiences now enabling enabling highly
connected and and collaborative type of
virtual workspaces are top priority for
organizations who want to ensure a
resilient future and organizations they
are prioritizing scaling virtual
products and virtual services and aiming
to be Leaders with delivering all kinds
of new forms of Engagement in this
digital world
but as organizations expand their
infrastructure to accommodate these new
technologies and these applications
architecture complexities increases well
as data volume grows and new
technologies and applications are
enabled it becomes difficult to connect
different type of environments and bring
visibility into many working components
of day-to-day type of business
operations and the complex architectures
now and as a result the businesses are
building new type of infrastructures
that consolidate and streamline
Technologies and applications and make
them more user friendly and make them
more accessible similar to mobile and
desktop type of experiences
now scaling and enabling technology and
enhancing collaborative experiences
between people and work introduces also
security risk and security
vulnerabilities and more organizations
than ever they are suffering all kinds
of data breaches and that's what we
we're going to discuss as well now
during this third quarter of 2022 we saw
15 million data records were exposed
worldwide through data breaches and this
is a 37 increase compared to the the
previous quarter and this is a
substantial uh substantial type of
increase and businesses need to think
about Security in a new context and
understand what internal and external
factors impact the security and what
impact businesses must bring the
feasibility and automation into their
entire business while simplifying the
security processes
and now what I see is well it's
imperative that companies enforce this
zero trust type of security
and this is very important and they also
try to unify their security environment
but as organizations as they scale their
technology
um their their reshaping their
engagement strategies and the further
streamline their infrastructure their
decisions will be influenced and it will
be driven by sustainability now all
technology Investments all the product
sales developments and the
infrastructure overhauls will be
weighted against their impacts on the
environment
now we see also sustainability this will
continue to be a major factor in in the
coming years and especially in 2023 as
organizations consider the the social
but also the the Regulatory and the
environmental impact of their business
and weave sustainability strategies into
their technology Frameworks and into
their business goals now businesses also
understand that consumers respond to to
brands that are environmentally
conscious at the same time we see that
the Next Generation Workforce
experiences will cater to Modern
um to Modern talents who prefer to be
employed by companies who are more
inclusive and we're also environmentally
conscious
and that's especially the younger
generation yeah really put an emphasis
on this
now organizations have to shape customer
and employee engagement strategies and
they have to do this with sustainability
at the 4. Forefront of their
considerations because if they don't it
will be hard to employ this gen z type
of um of employees
if we look to 2023 this will be a year
that businesses are excited I think and
they have to spend the last few years of
modernizing technology and
infrastructure to prepare for AI but now
they can really explore the potential
and to differentiate themselves by
enabling the Next Generation type of
experiences and Define the the future
for more intelligent and highly
immersive globally connected world and
they have the foundation for this right
now
now that businesses have later
technology foundation and digital
groundwork they can collaborate to this
new type of heights and they they make
Intelligent Decisions with Incredible
accuracy and introduce Automation and AI
everywhere now businesses are starting
to deeply understand the impacts of
their their data and their technology
environments and they unify their
business infrastructure so they can
create amazing new products new services
and new experiences that will shape and
Define our immersive connected
intelligent future
so now it's basically let's deep dive
and and start with Trend one
and Trend one is is the metaverse
now
if we talk about a metaverse global
immersive experiences
um this is one of the biggest Trends in
2023 and that's the metaverse and as I
said the metaverse is not only
um the b2c type of metaverse the maybe
the meta and the Facebook type of
metaphors that you know but also
especially the B2B where the business
cases are tremendously
um valid in them to to set up a digital
type of environment and to set up a
metaverse
um now just like the internet we will
see that people will be using a platform
for the metaverse and where they can
socialize where they can work where they
can connect
so you can just imagine what the
potential is of a single place that
brings everybody together in this
physical and in this digital realities
in in a simple in an interactive Type of
Way in a user-friendly type of way and I
think this is more the the b2c type of
application that that you are aware of
but the metaphors in the B2B will be
used
um is called digital twins that was what
I was explaining this Factory they
create a digital version of this and
that's a digital twin and the digital
twin is this digital version of a real
life object but also objects together
and then you create for example a
factory or a whole system or a whole
city can be digitalized and in the
context of of the metaverse a digital
train can be used to bring physical
spaces or objects into the virtual world
and this allows people to interact with
these type of digital versions in a more
immersive and in a more realistic way
and for example fully simulate this new
Factory building in operation and that's
before it's even built which I think is
quite amazing and this reduces the time
to set up a factory substantially and
this will help organizations to to speed
up all kinds of developments and also to
save substantial amount of cost in
creating new products and creating new
factories everything what's digital and
what can be created in a digital twin
they can save tons of cost
now if you think about it you can
witness the potential of the metaverse
when you're you're gaming for example
and it's more or less it looks like an
extend extending game that where you're
playing in so you can also use it for
attending online education you can you
will use it for social media or you can
use it for collaborating remotely at
work
and the future of an of the metaverse
is yeah it's still a kind of evolution
of these types of virtual experiences
where where people are virtually
connected globally through often a 5G
network if it's let's say not connected
to wired network but where 5G plays an
important role and where we have new
technologies coming up in two to three
years which are 5.5 G which are 10 times
faster and where you can create
metaverses with yourself in the
metaverse what I was explaining
and this this is extended reality and
this is built into our physical and into
our digital type of experiences
now
organizations what we see is that they
are exploring more business cases for
virtual reality
um also known as svr and also augmented
reality and this is more known as AR
and they use this for enhancing
collaboration and for digitizing
workflows now for example implementing
VR and AR Technologies into the design
process reshaping how people approach
Factory engineering by using VR displays
and to enhance Creative Design and and
create designs together with their VR
glasses on while being in different
physical locations
now also artificial intelligence is a
key component of shaping the metaverse
it's used in the creation of the avatars
and in the development of the virtual
worlds it's it's used in the compute um
for delivering the compute power
and the metaverse requires large and and
complex simulations and businesses need
to test and create this virtual
simulations that are built on this
Advanced Technologies like AI now
three-day worlds help organizations to
innovate and to explore all kind of new
possibilities in the metaverse and the
3D worlds they are required for other
Innovations like autonomous driving but
also for smart cities I was as I was
explaining
now because humans
I I'm quite excited and I think many
consumers are quite excited about the
metaverse when it comes to connecting
with others and collaborating with
colleagues which you can do remotely a
60 of the consumers prefer at least one
activity in an immersive world and it
doesn't have to be let's say the The
Meta the Facebook type of of metaphors
you have in mind it can be in all
different kinds of shapes and forms now
if we look to Executives in in
businesses Executives they are showing
strong signs of support as well 95 of
the executives believe that the
metaverse will positively impact their
industry which is really substantial and
that the metaphors would generate 5
trillion by 2030 already so you can see
that in the B2B markets the metaverse is
even much much bigger than it is in the
b2c market and the metaverse the
metaverse is still at the beginning
stages I think and in many aspects
they're going to be defined by how a
business innovates with new metaverse
services and with new type of
experiences
what we see is that the metaverse also
presents many challenges and one of the
big challenges for example High
connectivity and and computing power
requirements so as we were discussing
and this will be necessary to support
metaverse Innovation and the expansion
and I work closely for example with
companies like Intel and Nvidia and they
show and even a 1 million x Improvement
of compute power over the coming years
it's not 5x10x a 1 million x Improvement
of compute power which is really
incredible even to to imagine what what
kind of improvements we can expect over
there now if you can improve your
compute power you can improve your
simulations and your speeds and that
will provide all different kinds of new
possibilities with the metaphors for
example the organizations want to create
long-term value and they need to be
resilient in this coming future and the
metaphors becoming a popular choice of
fueling this Innovation and to ensuring
the continuity of the the companies now
if we look at the first half of 2020 to
companies have invested more than 120
billion in reshaping the metaverse
infrastructure and technology which is
more than twice as much as all of 2021
so you see there's big investments in
the metaphors and also for you if you
think about
um you know starting with with data
science starting working on machine
learning this can be an area where you
can further develop and where companies
need experts now the metaverse also ties
directly into modern Trends such as
inclusivity and sustainability too and
improving areas like healthcare for
example with connected Telehealth and
enhanced type of Coordinated Care remote
care and public sector by enhancing city
services and planning basically yeah
it's it's going to be everywhere the
metaverse creates an inclusive
environment where geographical barriers
don't exist anymore and this breaks down
basically Global barriers and if there's
Global barriers initially for example
you had Global barriers for Education
there will be less barriers now you can
of course do all three mode but it if
you can have one-on-one education in a
virtual world there's no barriers
anymore the same with collaboration the
same with development for products for
example
now businesses are investing a lot of
money and a lot of time in creating new
metaverse type of experiences and
they're more personalized and puts
people in front and center as the
creators of their own experiences now
from digitally projecting their own
physical image into the metaverse using
5G and iot cameras for example so you
can interact with the metaverse and with
others around you but for this type of
Technology you need faster internet and
that's either 5.5 G which requires I
think a minimum of the 500 megabit per
second or you can use for example AI as
a creative tool to help you with your
everyday
users to build all kinds of 3D new new
worlds now the metaverse what we just
see is is a massive opportunity for
organizations to deliver the next
generation of experiences and therefore
I think it's a massive opportunity for
you as well to say hey I'm going to be
an expert in all everything that's
required to build and support companies
in in the metaverse
so that's basically the first Trend
let's go to the next Trend and that's
super apps
now
this is also an important trend for 2023
and why it's enabling the next
generation of experiences now we have
talked about how the future will be
built on the global immersive connective
experiences and Super X being bring the
convenience of Technology platform
features and applications in into one
place so people can use Services they
want quickly and they can collaborate
effectively at work for example but also
privately
now if you look at Super apps they
combine the features of of apps and the
platform into some kind of single space
and the idea is that any user like
consumer or an employee can access a
core set of existing platform features
Plus have access to any independent
smaller type of apps and the platform
features and the applications exist
inside that single platforms
now if you think about consumers
employees Executives they can use the
features and the apps they want and they
can personalize it for their own
experiences and users can activate or
remove applications at any time now
because super apps exist on the platform
they have convenient features like
messaging and payments and everybody
knows in the meantime what Elon Musk
wants to do with Twitter he wants to
make it's a messaging system a payment
system on Twitter so he wants to build a
super app from from Twitter as well
now super super apps in the future they
are going to spend to to expand to
support this immersive type of metaverse
experience as well and probably as well
iot type of Technology but I will
explain that later our practical example
of super apps for consumers would be the
Consolidated features of a mobile
applications like Financial Service
customers who use mobile banking apps or
you just like how you can make make
payments view your accounts or access
your credit cards and score on your
mobile banking app and everybody knows
the super apps once that's coming is
Twitter but other ones which are very
popular for example in China but also
outside of China which is weak yet
and some other super apps include for
example grep
especially in in the southeast Asia this
is a very popular app and this allows
users to access a variety of services
you can think about retailing or food
delivery and digital payments and this
is all from a single platform and
additionally some global companies such
as Google and apple and and as mentioned
Twitter they are developing their own
type of super super app like platforms
that offer a wide range of services to
their users
now examples of super apps in business
would be creating engaging employee
experiences by enabling mini apps for a
large user base so they can use specific
tools and services to improve their
workflow and to improve their
collaboration so also in the B2B side
you will see developments of the super
apps and practically speaking I think
Super apps in business are similar to
what you call a platform as a service
also called pass for example so a pass
cloud
type of solutions platform and another
term which is is used now is low code or
no code type of application platforms
which are also basically yeah super
super apps foundations
and super apps make it easy to to access
a broad range of services and tools from
a user standpoint so it helps Engineers
it helps developers it helps it
professionals to build super apps and
add or remove mini apps for users very
easily and all the while businesses can
benefit from this platform features for
for data sharing you can use for example
the authentication which is critical but
also user tracking and then preferences
as you know in every platform where you
go yeah your data is stored is tracked
and you want to either you can either
control it or and sometimes it's limited
and that's how these companies earn
money as well with their data
now the bottom line is that that
consumers need Super apps for
Consolidated features for their mobile
and for the desktop experiences and
businesses they need this type of super
apps to create engaging employee
experiences so users and teams they can
access and they can collaborate and
activate any type of services that they
need and there have been some some
surveys and over 72 percent of the
surveyed consumers globally expressed an
interest in using these type of super
apps because of the reasons like being
able to to coordinate different type of
aspects of your life into a single app
into a similar location and reducing the
risk of losing any kind of sensitive
data
now
think about
um this little last time you buy past
for example
um going to a bank because you deposited
your your check online maybe some people
don't even know what that means
um then they decided to pay your credit
cards on the same banking app so you see
the developments in the financial
payments which are going quite quickly
or another example is where you're
working from home and using
collaborative Technologies to make calls
and to coordinate
now super apps are are being used mostly
for mobile technologies what we see but
they can also apply it in any type of
context as well
I want to address one more app that
recently has been launched and it's not
really a the falling into the category
of super apps but it's definitely an app
that will change everybody's life the
coming year and if you haven't heard of
it you need to research it and this is
chat GPT now when it comes to generating
natural
sounding text the GPT and GPT stands for
generative pre-training Transformer this
is one AI model that has proven itself
very effective with machine translation
with language simulation with content
generation and this is just a few
examples of this natural language
processing applications that have
benefits and this is from the team from
the open AI team who created this
now conversation conversational GPT
models or this also called chat GPT
models they're specialized forms of the
GPT that have been taught to hold
natural sound in conversations with
people so you ask a question you get an
answer and these type of models they are
frequently
employed to create
conversational type of chatbots and the
virtual assistants but this one this
chat GPT is really the next level so
models of the jet TPT they are trained a
massive collections of of human speeds
and they're allowing them to produce
answers that are natural and that are
relevant to the context in which they
were generated and they can be
customized to perform better in
particular domains or with a certain set
of topics
and to give a few examples how it will
change your life basically everybody's
life
um normally you go to Google and you you
type in a specific search or you maybe
ask a question but now instead of
getting 10 hundred thousand ten
thousands of search results you need to
go through
you get an answer
so every knowledge question
can be answered by chat GTP
now if you need to write a text for
example whether it's a Facebook ad
whether it's an article whether it's an
intro email whether it's summarizing a
piece of text you just give the query to
the chat of GPT and it writes very
useful text for you the more context you
give the better it can write the text
fitting exactly your purpose and it's
it's really amazing and only those these
two aspects what will change your life
if you start using it and just try it
out and you can experience the power of
of AI language models which yeah you see
right now it's really start working to a
level that it's tremendously easy to use
so what we see is that super apps
they're driving the next generation of
experiences for consumers for employees
but also for businesses by enabling
people to use the services and they want
to conveniently in their social and in
their work lives and sharing data across
services that helps organizations to
create connected experiences and by by
creating this together with the features
and the capabilities that the super apps
have and and businesses have a lot of
opportunities to further streamline user
experiences and differentiate themselves
with the next generation of experiences
so if you like this type of apps it's
definitely something you need to dive
into and you can start helping
businesses developing these type of
super apps and create the next type of
experiences that are going to change the
world and I think that's a nice moment
to go to the strength number three and
Trend number three is the sustainability
over here I'm in Europe it's a very hot
topic but I think it's a Hot Topic
everywhere and
where we look at Ai and Technology trend
for 2023 this sustainability is a
crucial subject
that defines for Our Generation but also
for the Next Generation which is
important as well so organization across
the industries they must reduce the
carbon footprint and they must meet the
regulatory requirements that demand The
Net Zero which is an agreement by 2050.
so AI is a critical component in helping
organizations to innovate with this new
sustainability type of solutions
so businesses are driving value and
revenue with analytics and with AI
environmental sustainability initiatives
so for example in consumer focused
Industries
businesses are embracing
accountable sustainability
so this is a governance-based approach
to data management so companies can
transparently share environmental goals
corresponding actions to take and report
and measure consistent progress so they
can adopt
um the governance best practices and
they can help stakeholders to be held
more accountable for their
sustainability efforts and people want
transparency they want to understand
what each company is doing in to help
reaching the sustainability goal so it's
more important more and more important
to become transparent in this domain as
well now if you look in the supply chain
and in manufacturing we see smart
factories are connecting physical
digital and experimental Technologies
and integrating them together to create
sustainable type of solutions now they
are built from from the ground up to
address this future environmental needs
such as being built in a net zero
building powered
um by which is powered and more by by
renewable energy and powered by smart
grids which is using effective Waste
Management efforts to and recyclable
materials it's using smart lighting it's
using solar panels and using all
different kind of activities to reduce
the carbon footprint
if we look in the public sector for
example we have climate change and
government action coincide
so data and analytics are helping
governments to embrace solutions that
Target climate change which impact the
public sector and which impacts also the
communities
and this is done by targeting Creative
Solutions and by decarbonizing and
achieving a net zero
um a net zero type of approach and
introducing for example electric fleet
vehicles for governments but also
committing to renewable type of energy
Frameworks to help governments integrate
modern Energy Solutions and accelerate a
lower carbon future or even a net zero
carbon future
now individual sectors also present
large opportunities for organizations to
create value in their sustainability
initiatives
I have to give a couple of examples of
building and Contracting companies they
can build Net Zero buildings as
construction accounts for 40 percent of
the global CO2 emissions so they they
need to do something and construction
and contract Contracting companies that
can Implement efficiency announcing
building materials or they can use green
engineering they can use Performance
Management systems and also low carbon
heating and cooling systems which are
driven by AI
and also energy grids which are driven
by by AI look in the automotive industry
Now cars and tracks are responsible for
75 of the carbon emissions for Mobility
now vehicle manufacturers must
decarbonize the vehicles and they must
Embrace battery and hydrogen fuel cell
electric vehicles as well so there's two
Trends in this in this area
if we look through some studies for
example show that organizations need
sustainability software to monitor
social and environmental sustainability
and this can be real-time type of
monitoring and software vendors play a
key role in helping organizations to
track their environmental social and
governance
um performance goals the ESG as they're
known as and so the businesses can set
targets and they meet their
attainability goals
another example data centers they're
also Target for sustainability as they
account for one percent of the global
energy consumption now as organizations
data use increase green development in
the data center becomes a targeted area
for reducing the impact of a business
carbon footprint
the future of of data architectures will
have Advanced Data Centric Computing
architectures that reduces computing
power and data migration
and green development has become a key
buzzword to describe these industries
that are going to be intelligent and
that are using Technology Solutions for
this lower carbon type of development
and businesses are building
decarbonization strategies to build
around these green development and this
is contributing to the industry-specific
sustainability Trends in 2023 and
there's a lot of pressure on it and it
can be in areas like construction the
public sector manufacturing industry so
if you you like to contribute
to the sustainability there's different
Industries take industries that
um that are the biggest pollution type
of Industries and you can contribute a
lot so sustainability is becoming a way
for organizations to deliver this next
generation of experiences to increase
revenue and regulatory requirements for
carbon neutral future and you can
contribute to it and that brings us
basically to the next topic which is
observability and AI
and this is the the last technology
Trend that we're going to discuss for
2023 now we've talked about how
organizations are going to innovate and
differentiate themselves with with all
kinds of new metaverse and services
um
and
these metaphors have to bring also new
type of experiences
we then delved into how consumers and
businesses are going to be using these
super apps to make it easier to to use
the features we want to in our mobile
and desktop type of applications and we
talked about how companies across the
industries are using AI for example for
sustainability
now at this point our organizations
going to create these engaging
experiences like that in the metaverse
and the super apps and drive social and
environmental sustainability
they must practice observability
which delivers an end-to-end view of
their data the Technologies and the
processes so observability brings
visibility across the entire Enterprise
so everything what you don't see so that
businesses can determine the root cause
of anomalies are just internal
strategies and take appropriate actions
in real time in constantly involving
world so is everything is digital and
either as somewhere a bridge or a hack
they need to act in a split second or
even need to act before it happens with
the help of AI now key channels for
organizations is to keep the systems and
applications up and running and
observability has has many benefits
including the ability to detect the root
cause of application failures or
drastically reducing application down
times you don't want your app to be down
that's the worst experiences that you
can bring Now application downtime can
cost companies 28 million just one
company annually
but this can be reduced to around 2
million a year with observability
practices so this has a tremendous
return
now the metaphors and the super apps and
the environmental sustainability use
cases require this always on approach of
your operation there is no downtime
anymore and these Trends they can't
exist if systems and applications are
inoperable
so observability helps organizations to
better understand their entire data life
cycle and their end-to-end business and
technology environment and their
processes
let me give an example
so if some if systems are down as a
result of an application failure or a
security breach now as a business adopt
more data and more technology
infrastructures become more complex
while
security risks rise
another organizations need to innovate
and to protect their organization from
threats and in real time and respond to
to all kind of changing market dynamics
with the agility and and the speed
and the rise of cloud usage creates
these hybrid architectures and
multi-cloud environments while Cloud
applications are a significantly on the
rise
and Business Leaders they're also under
a lot of pressure to expand their
technology to expand the cloud to expand
their observability knowledge to retain
and to hire new talent and respond to
this High attrition and improve the
project performance so this is also an
area
if you like to work with large amounts
of data like to detect anomalies for
example this is an area where where you
should think about and when technology
environments and data are unified and
visibility is extended across the
Enterprise
business can introduce Automation and
intelligence everywhere and enable this
next Generation experiences but without
this
it's one big failure it's it's not going
to work you need to provide this
Foundation of observability and for
organizations to take advantage of
observability
for for use cases like monitoring and
management and then they need to ensure
that AI is completely embedded in it
operations they need data
standardization is the characteristics
of the entire ecosystem to prevent any
skewing of outcomes they need to ensure
they they pivot observability practices
to the cloud
the observability will be a key practice
for organizations if they're going to
deliver that is differentiated next
generation of of experiences
now we went through all these Trends
let's now talk about the educational
path
um for for AI applications online
Education certification companies
like simpler and they uniquely
positioned to help you to prepare for
these type of future trends
and
if you yeah think about going into a
certain direction it's always good to
think about what's happening next where
will be the demands and the demands will
be in the areas
where the trends are so these are four
areas if you want to be sure for a job
in the coming years these are four areas
which I highly recommend
and as mentioned before yeah we virtual
learning breaks down the geographical
barriers
it also promotes inclusive learning
environments and it coincides with early
developments of the metaverse as well
what we see now they're creating by
either these e-learning companies and
there's many opportunities and benefits
that online Education certification
companies can provide you to give an
example their infrastructures they are
agile they are adaptable which allows
them to offer up to up-to-date
curriculum that's on target with this
new type of trends like the the 2023 AI
technology trends like we're discussing
now
but also
um you can work at your own pace and you
can watch
specified video content on any type of
device it makes it makes it easy and
then also not to mention that online
Education certification companies
partner with leading universities
um universities like like Caltech on or
Purdue and then partner with companies
companies like the biggest tech
companies like Amazon and Microsoft to
ensure that you receive top tier
education and you are prepared for your
career
it's a company and you know exactly
what's what's their demand and so if
you're interested in working for example
in the metaverse fields there are
specific skills that can help you secure
a job role for example blockchain and
the nft engineering type of skills and
they can assist companies in developing
a decentralized web3 infrastructure and
can a computer
accompanying assets that will be
essential to the metaverse development
and to the administration so this is an
area what you can can dive into some
skills that would be required for for
the role as an NFD smart contract
developer for example would be
experiencing in Python my experience in
JavaScript probably and you also need
blockchain technology expertise such as
ethereum or solidity and you need web3
integration knowledge that would be a
great asset for you as well now you
might also want to pursue education in
augmented reality or VR virtual reality
because these are key these are really
key to this immersive type of
experiences and the interfaces that
companies need more and more so if you
want to be an AR or VR developer on AI
AR VR engineer
skills that you should require should
include experience in languages like C
plus plus or c-sharp or python or Swift
and JavaScript you also need a deep
understanding of ux and UI programming
and what would be good to know is is 3D
modeling
um
like polygon polygonal for example
um or a computer science degree or
certification is also helpful
particularly if if it's an advanced
degree like like a master's degree
now if helping
to contribute to sustainability is more
your type of of your cup of tea then
you're in look because data scientists
are incredibly valuable for helping to
combat the climate change to give an
example you could become a smart Factory
operation engineer or smart Factory
automation system engineer and then you
need
knowledge of iot and and cut income
software for example you also need
expertise in in C plus plus or in Java
or in in Matlab and experience in
robotics and you have companies for
example who are very good at this is ABB
now
then you have Vision system experience
where we can think about for example
cognex which is another important skill
you could also pursue jobs as a climate
modeling machine learning engineer or a
climate data analyst or air quality
modeling engineer so you see that jobs
become more and more and more and more
specific to a specific purpose to a
specific industry and there's numerous
out-of-the-box type of roles associated
with sustainability and fighting climate
change today so you might yeah even find
other creative options other creative
namings of jobs depending on the
industry and the interest that you have
um also a good Educational Foundation is
skills in like data wrangling machine
learning deep learning statistical
Computing
multivariate calculus data visualization
Big Data Frameworks and this can help
you to be attractive to to different
kinds of potential employers
and then you can perform tasks like
predicting clean power supply demands or
you can develop a green infrastructure
and maybe you're interested in the
future in super app developments or in
engineering
for example if you want to be a full
stack engineer for a super develop for
super app development
then you want skills in in web and in
mobile applications and server-side
components and you also want skills in
for example typescript or JavaScript or
PHP and the associated framework like
node GS or react
and you need expertise as more as a
foundation in no SQL and SQL databases
and and devop testing tools like CID CD
tools GitHub jira and Docker now again
computer science degrees or
certifications can help you here
and I want to to add here that for any
future career it touches any of these AI
Trends you need some soft skills as well
soft skills often are forgotten you can
think about the ability to communicate
effectively which is very important and
to work well with others and yeah do
some critical thinking and adaptability
and and storytelling to to share the
trends now let's let's conclude enabling
Next Generation experience in 2023 will
require businesses to unify their data
to unify the technology the business
environment and that can bring
end-to-end visibility across the
Enterprise and begin to explore exciting
new use cases for the metaverse for
super apps for sustainability and yeah I
think that's a nice Foundation you can
contribute to in the coming years and
I'm looking forward to some questions
maybe you have some questions Stuart in
the meantime
I can't hear you so
pardon me I forgot I I muted myself
um first question that came in is from
manage who asks how AI relates to
condition monitoring
um yeah so if if you look to condition
monitoring um it's it's the process of
monitoring the condition of machines or
systems or orders to identify any
problems or issues that that arise if
that's the area
um what he's talking about so
AI can be used in condition monitoring
to improve the accuracy and the
efficiency of processes so AI algorithms
can be used to analyze the data
collected by a condition monitoring
sensors in real time they can identify
all kinds of patterns and trends that
may present a problem that can go occur
so you can basically detect already
outages and AI can be used to to detect
them and you can do predictive
maintenance before the issue basically
occurs and it can be used to to automate
and fully the analysis process and it
can free up the technicians and the
engineers to focus on other tasks and
only focus on when it's required so it's
not let's say traditional type of
Maintenance where you do maintenance
every month on the machine now you can
do it when needed and AI can be used I
think to improve the performance and the
condition monitoring of sensors and the
systems where you can have machine
learning algorithms that can be used to
optimize the placements and the
configuration of sensors for for example
so there's all different kinds of areas
where Ari can be used in condition
monitoring and help either prevent
issues or optimize the operation
okay
thank you for that and um
we have a question about from Jason who
asked they have companies fully embraced
things like chat GPT for customer
service and support
GDP is launched now three weeks ago
um in the first week it was downloaded I
think more than one million times so I'm
not sure but I don't think that many
companies have embraced it already I
know already some companies that
provided automated writing services
like Sonic writer they created already a
chat GPT Sonic
writer version
um so they were one of the the first
ones where I saw it so you see now
companies developing their own
applications or new models on chat GPT
and I expect initially everybody will
start using it and you start discovering
it how you can use it either for writing
your ads for writing your articles for
giving support to helping in your
customer service process for example but
it's so new that yeah I haven't seen it
yet but maybe it's there already maybe
some company is our developing it and
they will come to Market shortly but
it's yeah it's an amazing technology and
I really recommend you have a look at it
because the tool itself can help you
already and even yeah it can help the
companies and on a bigger scale as well
but let's start using it first
individually they say it can even be a
direct competitor
search engines like Google
interesting and it represents a big step
up from the current use of AI and
customer support which is pretty uh
there will be many use cases which we
probably have not thought about now and
on the other hand I see already new
versions new features popping up every
week they're scaling up and so yeah I
expected development will go fast but I
think the the nice thing about jet GPT
um I think if you look to all the
chatbots that were there in the market
and they're not always gave a good
experience didn't answer your questions
didn't respond and maybe just a menu
this is really the next level of having
a normal conversation with the person
you can ask any question and you get an
answer whether it's an answer what it is
or to write certain texts and yeah as I
said that that will change especially
the marketing industry the writing
industry the knowledge industry because
the the CEO from chat GTP said knowledge
becomes basically zero value because it
will be delivered by Ai and that's quite
an old statement yeah
um
that it's like the the story that our
brains will become atrophied because
everything we need to know is on Google
and it's what people used to say a few
years ago but
um
supermania asked a question is is AI
useful in Sports Development how would
that work
yeah so AI is used in sports already for
quite a while
um initially you can collect data so for
example if you have a specific sport
um football and you put sensors on every
player on one hand if you're collecting
data about the position of each player
and which let's say combinations where
certain players are and certain tactics
which tactics work which tactics
delivers to results it also for example
monitors the the health the physical the
especially the physical health of each
person and by using this data you can
let's say initially provide insights but
if you start predicting okay which type
of combinations can work best or let's
machine learning algorithms basically
calculate how you should play how long
you should have a ball position
where you yeah how much you should work
it can basically advise you in every
step and can be a support to you as a
coach to take smarter decisions based on
data
versus based on your gut feeling as a
coach Moneyball is a nice example of
course which the the movie where it's
all data driven and sports will become
more more data driven another example
where technology is used tremendously is
for example with formula one on one end
Formula One during the race they
calculates
um yeah every time I think they do one
billion calculations for Red Bull that's
one billion calculations during a race
to make decisions and you can imagine
that every second that the whole field
changes situation changes and based upon
this
um yeah algorithms are running what's
the next best decision
um should you change tires what type of
tires
um when you when you should go into the
bids when not and yeah during a race
that's calculated that's one part the
other part is for the design of the the
new car and they designed it basically
in the Wind Tunnel because the downforce
initially when you were driving behind
another car the downforce was reducing I
think by 48 percent
and that meant that you could not pass
the car once you're behind it to have
more wheel to reel racing they wanted to
um reduce this this downforce so they
created a new design and they used fluid
um computational Dynamics to calculate
millions of calculations what the effect
is from each change and they came up
with a new design of the car and now you
see this season a lot of wheel to reel
racing and if somebody passes one car if
a micro stopper passes Leclair Leclair
has immediately the possibility to pass
him again because he doesn't lose the
downforce and this makes Sports
especially in Formula One which was more
racing behind each other in the past and
now it's really wheel to Wheel racing
makes a tremendous difference in the
experience that it delivers in sports
great I have one I think you have to
leave shortly but I have one last
question if you have time for it
yep shortly
um so Raphael asks about who are the the
leaders in metaphors for industrial
applications as opposed to meta for
Consumer and
um
what types of companies are involved in
things like digital twins
yeah so
um let's talk about the leaders so
there's multiple
um
companies that deliver compute companies
like Nvidia companies like Intel where
Nvidia is really taking a strong lead in
in this domain I think
um so
there are more let's say companies who
dive into this but these are our leaders
and if you look for example to nvidia's
annual presentations or bi-annual
presentations you see yeah amazing
metaverse type of applications whether
it's creating this this digital
factories a BMW Factory which is created
ruined before it's even built but also
creating digital avatars if you go to my
LinkedIn and you go to my LinkedIn and
search for the the featured items you
see a whole series of of metaverse
applications how AI contributes to
simulations to creating digital avatars
to creating digital twins
um and yeah I I let's say get all the
newest type of developments I get
delivered by these tech companies and uh
yeah there you see what what is possible
I'm I missed the second question so this
was about the digital twins yeah yeah I
mean I think you covered a lot of that
but the if there are particular vendors
who help in digital twins
yeah so I think what you see is if you
help in the metaverse the technology is
is similar it's about creating
simulations virtual simulations and
whether you use it for creating an
avatar or whether you create it for B2B
digital twins the technology is the same
and these companies yeah they operate
basically in both spaces
um if that's all the time you have uh
Ronald I can let you go otherwise
let me know if you have time for another
question or two let's do one one more
question then okay
um I think one more question
um
let's see
the interesting question from sadipta
who asked how AI can distinguish from
misinformation and disa information
and whether there's a potential for a
service or a business model based on
that capability
yeah so
um misinformation disinformation and I
think typical the social networks have a
big challenge in defining what is real
and what's fake
so on one hand let's say defining
whether it's real or fake it's a
personal validation so if somebody posts
something people are reviewing certain
content then they can say hey it's real
or it's fake
and the other part is for example like
this jet DP is doing is checking all the
data that's online reasoning whether
it's logical and whether it's true and
then true is it can be let's say
objective it can be subjective so true
is a very broad spectrum and at a
certain moment you need to say okay this
is so far out of the reality and I think
during covet this this was a very um
very good case where yeah there were all
kinds of stories about how to get go
with the strange stories and I'm not
going to mention them
um as even it can get flagged on on
YouTube or something to get banned but
the the algorithms can detect whether
things are within the spectrum of
reality or outside of the spectrum of
reality and that's what's happening with
with fake news it's happening for
example with Bots I'm currently on
Twitter Twitter
um is removing Bots substantially
and they do this with the help of AI
to find out the type of messaging and
how they message if they're typing if
they're posting messages in real time so
there's all different kind of of checks
in real time to Define its fake news or
it's real and as I said fake and real is
is still a gray area because it can be
your opinions but sometimes yeah this
algorithms Define okay it's uh it's fake
and one very easy example what you see
now if you go on Twitter you see often
the Tweet being blacked out and say this
has sensitive data and it's based upon
image recognition it can be based upon
the text it can be on links that are
sent somewhere so there's multiple type
of text not only text checks visual type
of text and video type of text to find
out if it's appropriate or not
thank you for that and thank you very
much for the session uh Ronald I'm going
to continue on but I know that you have
time constraint to leave so can can I
just log off or just go go right ahead
and I will share with our audience
the um information on how to contact you
um first I'm going to
um thank you all
pretty much and first I'm going to
mention one of our uh good to learn
programs which is
uh the postgraduate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning from Caltech
this is the version of our program
that's offered outside of the United
States
there's another version that's offered
within the United States this one is an
11 month program it's fully online
and it features live virtual classrooms
meeting weekly so that time face to face
with your instructor and your your
classmates
and it takes you through integrated labs
and Hands-On projects if you use the QR
code there it will take you to the
page on our website for this program but
um it covers an extensive uh
comprehensive
curriculum including artificial
intelligence python machine learning
Keras and tensorflow for deep learning
uh Advanced deep learning and Machine
Vision
it has a Capstone project that lets you
integrate all of those skills into one
industry-based solution for a problem
um that you then use as an Exemplar of
how you do work in Ai and throw that off
to potential future employers
it allows you to take electives
data science and statistics and NLP uh
speech recognition reinforcement
learning and an academic master classes
from both Caltech ctme instructors as
well as IBM industry experts so
proposes you to a number of different
tools and platforms more than exposes
you it requires you to use them in the
position in them so that you can add
those to your resume with confidence
um
so in this 90-second description just
curious to know uh who in the audience
might be interested in
more about this program
just do a quick pull
we'll keep this open for a few seconds
I'll be sharing with you how to get more
information about this
we'll close the poll in about 10 seconds
or so
all right
so
okay more than 80 percent of our
audience said that uh they'd be
interested uh certainly or perhaps in
this program so we'll share with you
information about that and uh
well about half of you are looking to do
this something uh Beyond six months some
of you are looking to do this fairly
soon so
uh again the QR code gives you
information but the best way to get
direct information is to email us at ask
us at simplylearn.net
I am going to put into
chat the link to this program page in
case you don't want to get your phone
out to scan the QR code
let me do that
that's in the chat and I will also put
the email addresses in the chat now as
well
and
as I promised here is Ronald's LinkedIn
information I will put this URL in the
chat for you so you can just grab that
you can also find Ronald Van Loon by
Googling
I think it's a link there and
please reach out to him on LinkedIn
you had questions that we couldn't cover
because of time limitations uh he may be
able to help you with those through that
connection
um
do want to thank everyone who came out
for this presentation today this evening
and this morning depending on where you
are in the world thank you all for being
here we are very pleased to have you and
our audiences and we hope that we'll see
you at future
simply when webinars connect with us on
Facebook and Linkedin at simply learn or
uh or pardon me Facebook and Twitter at
simplylearn LinkedIn simply learn and
then
we also hope that we can welcome you
into the simply learned learning
community
again
that concludes our webinar and thank you
for being here